new development in a story about a
popular tourist destination we first
told you about earlier this week our
lead national correspondent that's david
beck now travel to calebra that's off
puerto rico's main island to report on a
hidden danger the nearly 1800 year-round
residents and the tourists who travel
there lacked access to critical
emergency medical care david is here now
with this morning he's got an update for
us it seems like your reporting made a
difference well we heard there were some
things happening behind the scenes gayle
and sure enough last night the
government sent out a tweet and it was
official
so before our reports aired on monday
and tuesday of this week the island of
culebra had no paramedics working 24
hours a day seven days a week and there
were no available ambulances stocked
with emergency supplies but just last
night the government of puerto rico
announced on twitter that they have sent
resources to collabra here's the deal a
team of two paramedics will be sent from
the main island and they will be
stationed on kulebra they're going to
work seven days a week from 7 a.m to 3
p.m and they're going to be on call at
night they're going to change crews
weekly and these medics will operate an
ambulance that has all the necessary
equipment to save someone's life now the
central government posted these pictures
of officials who met with cu labor's
mayor elder berto romero levette
who we spoke to in our report and they
even visited flamenco beach which has
been the site of recent drownings on
culebra that beach is ranked one of the
world's top beaches in the world i mean
you've got tourists that flock there
every year and the government spends
millions of dollars trying to tell
people go there to enjoy it
after our report aired puerto rico's
health secretary actually sent our story
to members of congress saying hey here's
a problem we need money to fix it the
reality is it's been a problem for a
long time right so why did it take this
report to sort of ask for that and two
things i've heard from people saying
david i hope this isn't just them
embarrassed by the report jumping and
reacting is this going to be a permanent
fix and also paramedics have reached out
to me from like new york and florida and
said i'll go there i'll volunteer and
i'm like if you're serious call the
mayor because he'll take your call but
david they know that you'll be there if
they don't live up to their promise
that's what journalism does but this is
a big deal yeah right why did it take
this report to get that for the people
who locally lived there and the people
who visit listen it's never too late to
do the right thing but there's no
question they saw your report and
certainly heard from the victims who
have lost someone and said we got to do
something this is exactly why we do what
we do right well david yes thank you